se jode seguridad de las naciones unidas
convocó una sesión extraordinaria de
emergencia de la asamblea general sobre
la invasión rusa de ucrania que está
prevista para celebrarse este lunes la
reunión se aprobó con 11 votos a favor 3
abstenciones de los emiratos árabes
unidos china e india- y sólo uno en
contra el de rusia la federación rusa
votó en contra del proyecto de
resolución presentada en relación con el
hecho de que sus patrocinadores
proponían que se registrara que el
consejo de seguridad no había ejercido
su responsabilidad primordial de
mantener la paz y la seguridad
internacional al mismo tiempo no vimos
ni siquiera un indicio de intento de
alcanzar una solución constructiva en el
consejo el procedimiento solicitado por
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
está permitido por una resolución de
1950 llamada unidos por la paz que
permite a los miembros del consejo de
seguridad convocar a la asamblea general
a una sesión especial si los cinco
miembros permanentes rusia eeuu reino
unido francia y china no logran ponerse
de acuerdo entre ellos para juntos y
mantener la paz
paintball con youtube rave list a medida
que el pueblo ucraniano continúa
enfrentándose valientemente a la
agresión rusa las mentiras de rusia
quedarán expuestas y se confirmará el
desprecio de rusia por el derecho
internacional
ucrania para que rusia rinda cuentas
con el embajador de ucrania para las
naciones unidas también afirmó que su
país busca una orden de que rusia debe
detener su ataque ilegal